what's up everybody I got a new date
added January 26 to the 28th Phoenix
Arizona brand new hour of standard
material January 26 to the 28th Phoenix
Arizona stand up live then of course we
got December 15 16 17th in Charlotte
Asheville in Charleston December 31st
Huntington New York and then we got
January 12th in New Orleans January 13th
in Dallas January 14th in Houston but
January 26-28 Phoenix Arizona and
Buffalo New York you got moved to May
5th because of the snowstorm
christycomedy.com for tikiwickies
[Music]
all right baby we got another hey babe
we got another hey babe and Sal is back
this is Sal hi guys Sal the Sal has come
back and he's wearing it one of those
disguised faces you buy at a costume
store yes it was very expensive it's
what we like to call a practical joke
hey Sal's background he's bisexual and
he's really living his best life yes
he's finally living his dreams it's just
Joe DeRosa he's Satan yeah I um thank
you for coming this is of course Ian
finance a good friend of the show the
only member he did back to back episodes
Ian yes I was so honored to give you a
two-parter it was amazing and I get to
tell you thank you to people that are
coming out to shows and like saying hi I
get so much love like oh I saw you and
hey babe it's amazing it's the best
thank you that's why we do the show we
appreciate it yeah um I just got over
the flu
um I'm still actually not over it I
don't think I'm contagious though
anymore
you invite me into this high-rise first
of all you know I'm like a two pack a
day smoker and you're like come to the
this floor and then walk up seven
flights of stairs yeah I get here I'm
hacking and wheezing then you're like oh
I still have a viral load I got a viral
and then he comes in he goes he goes he
goes sorry I'm late I just have to clean
up all this [ __ ] water off my floor in
my apartment all right handshake I'm
like thanks [ __ ] fingers I got [ __ ]
figures you got sick mouth I mean but
more like a gay couple in the 80s I know
uh but yeah dude I um it's I feel I
don't know if you ever had the flu man
but I I I feel better I was sick the
last couple days fever and headache and
all that but dude I am so fatigued like
I genuinely I I'm it is Le it's the
fatigue that's like I can't explain it
dude I'm so tired did you get RSV no I
checked everything I checked covet RSV
they told me I have Aids on the flu wow
yeah well I can't get it because I heard
I thought you legit thought I had AIDS
what
also the comedy community would be like
of course extreme all right but like not
like insanely shocked water is wet you
know like we get it
let me call you for a telephone yeah
guys you need a quilt we need to tell
them
have you had the flu ever yes I've never
had it it's brutal what I know worse
than the other one dude I I was one of
those guys that like before like when
when are we allowed to say I mean we
just don't say it right yeah
believe that okay I had I had the bat
flu and uh that's better
yeah all right no I had the Yao Ming
I had to make you sick long time and uh
I didn't get it but I got violently ill
in February of 2020. so I was one of
those guys who was like dude not for
nothing but I think I was the first one
to get it yeah and it turns out that I
had just had a threesome in DC with two
Chinese people so I did get really a
certain type of vagina flu interesting
yes and you were and that was the
sickest you've ever been dude who's the
sickest you've ever been in your life
and what was that viral meningitis 19
year 18 years 19 years old okay in
college they told me if I had waited a
half hour more I would have died because
my brain was swelling so what happened
so so what was the first day of symptom
viral manager I said you know you were
sick it was in the morning I woke up and
felt like I just like got beat with a
bag of hammers all over your body all
over the body and then just the most
pounding headache I've ever had Advil
didn't work nothing worked and
throughout the day I couldn't keep my
eyes open and then I couldn't keep my
head up and I'd have a friend walk me
back to my dorm oh you were trying to go
to class yes and so you are not a [ __ ]
dude Briar the day before I was sweating
and feeling sick on an Amtrak headed
back to New York and I went to a deli
and I like kind of passed out a little
and knocked over like a thing uh
whatever's and I was like I think I'm
just tired and then uh I I know I know
and then the next day dude I'm telling
you by like four o'clock I could not
keep my head up everything hurt and I
laid I knocked on my RS door and was
like can you check on me and if I don't
answer the door in 15 20 minutes can you
just come in the room I've never felt
this sick in my life and she's like okay
so dude I laid down and I was just like
I I truly felt like I I was like Don
like it was terrible and then they
called an ambulance took me to the
hospital I had assignment they put me in
a wheelchair I couldn't even sign my
name and they immediately took me in
they gave me a spinal tap they knew you
had meningitis oh dude they knew
something was up like they Scoot and
Boot and beam right in and uh they gave
me a spinal tap a nine inch uh uh needle
and but you're used to nine inches
though oh yeah but not my spine it might
you know rectum in my China hole
yes yes all right yeah I bow and they
fill
um so dude but I remember they because
it was at uh the NYU Hospital like
Langhorn so they have you know like
interns and stuff are on the medical
rounds so they had like a med student
give me the spinal tap and I just heard
the guy go okay to the left to the left
to the left and I'm like oh
my God and dude I got it I immediately
puked they gave me like so much pain
medicine it didn't knock the pain they
had to call my mom and go is your son an
intravenous drug user because none of
this pain you uh medicine is like
touching the pain really yeah and then
the next morning I I like signed myself
out and just because whatever they had
given you kind of uh reverse the viral
meningitis the medicine worked like
pressure yeah but they were like if you
had waited a half hour like it's always
like isn't funny how like yeah you
always hear these stories are like if it
was a centimeter to the left you would
have died if it was a half hour lady you
wouldn't die I think they just want to
make you feel like you you're really
lucky get lucky or like yeah I'm the one
that saved you dude they said that there
was a guy who fell off the cruise ship
did you see this guy there's a pimp
Google this a guy fell off a cruise ship
last week was in the water for 15 hours
in the middle of the night and then got
saved by the Coast Guard they the Coast
Guard guy said he had 30 seconds to him
minute to live I'm like really what you
came in what is this are we in the
[ __ ] set of a movie 30 Seconds To
Live and you scooped them out of the
water how does he know how does he know
yeah dude stop you're gonna have 30
Seconds To Live he survived through the
night because and and you know they're
all trying to make family friendly
stories about this I was watching on the
news they're like even my mothers were
watching and she's like oh my God like
God's God must have had him in a
protective code I said he was on cocaine
he fell off the cruise ship because he
was on coke and booze it was a gay
cruise he was all messed and ketamined
up that's why he survived folks so
that's why I always have a bag of
cocaine yes what in your pocket on a
cruise ship in case you fall into the
water or in your ass the Lord's pocket
yeah imagine what goes through your head
after this guy he plummeted look this is
the guy he got in a uh uh his family
blames fall on fight and the guy what a
drunk [ __ ] fell off in dude you
didn't get eaten by a shark he didn't
get hypothermia you didn't get sucked in
by the propellers you stayed alive and
floated alive within 30 seconds of your
life supposedly because you were on coke
oh look at this look at this what do
they say what I can't okay there were
crew members uh I meant man anti-game
remarks didn't I say it was a gay cruise
that's it I knew it high lipstick that's
what they said
can you imagine right before you get
cartoonishly toss off a cruise over goes
High lipstick
no they said that the that the crew who
saved him said that so he's floating in
the water for 15 hours and then as he's
getting saved this night Shining Armor
goes what's up
I love it imagine they can't he's
playing hey little lady
oh god dude holy [ __ ] that is pretty
crazy they said there was a nautical
square miles of 931 miles and they found
them what if he survived because he had
a butt plug-in and it kept him buoyant
seriously
literally yeah he didn't take on any
water because he plugged up yeah he was
on coke and he had a butt plug in oh my
god dude that's wild speaking of butt
plugs Brendan Fraser defends wearing
Prosthetics to play obese man in the
whale it was accurate now this movie The
Whale is it out yet
or is it not out because because I
thought that that's what Brendan Fraser
looked like I thought I thought he
gained the weight gained the weight and
went bald but he's he he gained some
weight but I mean in the whale he's
messed what is it about I don't know
what the whale's even about it it is
funny though to have his face just be so
fat the whale I mean yeah that people
get that fat what do people they changed
the title originally it was supposed to
be called fat pig
what do people expect them to hire a 600
pound person to work out like 12 hours a
day dude not only that it's like they
want these it's like well it has to be a
realistic thing let's find the
.0001 of the population that's a
massively obese man that's also a grade
A actor it's like what are we doing no
it's acting it does dude I don't want to
see this movie as much as I want to see
Let's Play the trailer for it if we
won't get flag of cocaine bear this is a
real movie that's coming out it is
coming out it has been made around it's
called cocaine bear it is there's a
great young comic in it I forget his
name it's the true story of a movie uh
pause it for a second it's a true story
of a of uh uh it's a true story of a uh
bear that got into
um bricks of cocaine that had fallen off
a plane somewhere I I wanted I don't
know actually where it was but it ate
through like three like kilos of coke
and then went on the Savage spree of of
destroying all these animals in and
plants and then died of a heart attack
and they made a movie about it who's in
the movie what comics in the movie uh a
younger guy let me find his name I just
found oh that guy
he's hilarious him is he a stand-up in
New York I don't know I believe he's a
stand-up yeah he's a stand-up and he
would do all these um like Ikea videos
and usually I hate like Tick-Tock front
faces he was great look at this cocaine
bear Tennessee look at this for this out
there they dumped it somewhere I
Knoxville Tennessee okay
something got into it a deer Maybe
look at this cocaine there this is the
type of movies we need to start to see
this movie Wow Let's see what kind of
effect that has on look at this
[Music]
the bear hey [ __ ] cocaine huh
[Music]
that's uh Ice Cube son a bear it was far
hey
dude it's great it looks great this
movie is this is the type of movies like
that I like I'm excited and this brings
me back to Tarantino on on sigura's pod
he said we live in the worst era of
movies ever in the history of the world
okay these last like 15 years so
hopefully [ __ ] like this comes out
[Music]
I mean I guess yeah the movies aren't
great do you think when the bear did all
that coke he was trying to tell our
other Bears long-winded stories yeah
yeah their businesses that would never
get off the ground yeah yeah dumb dumb
ideas of vodka Shake that's protein yeah
uh I I um that's great I yeah dude
cocaine bear is it's finally like yeah I
mean I'd see this over any Dwayne
Johnson movie yeah for sure like what do
you think's probably better do you think
cocaine Bears better or Black Adam
cocaine bear well Moe our friend Molly
mayor's in Black Adam I'd only watched
his scenes what is
Black Adams uh it was a new like uh a
documentary on the first black guy named
Adam ever yeah it's yeah it's uh I think
it's like a comic book movie right yeah
yeah
superhero movie there you go yeah see so
I have never seen a superhero movie you
know you're not into that interest yeah
I'm not I I remember when the pandemic
first started I watched all the Marvel
Avenger movies in order I did that with
the family
um oh my God yeah I remember because we
had so much time yeah it was almost 20
hours yeah I think yeah well no more I
think it was 12 or 14 movies each
movie's two three hours well they're all
there's like a thread throughout them
right so that's like their Continuing
Story yeah it continues and then that's
how many what do you guys think the
worst movie series of all time is the
worst movie series of all time uh
so
so I don't I didn't hate the saws I you
know what it is for me to be honest with
you where I think it just it it it it it
it got stupid I can't keep them all
together Spider-Man I think there were
too many Spidermans too many different
Spider-Mans too many I don't know who
the real Spider-Man is I don't know
where any of them was and then here's
another one I know I might get [ __ ] for
this but I'm just gonna say it fast and
the furious never cared you don't like
family
that was the strangest one they'll tell
you what the best movie series of all
time is what Back to the Future of one
two and three okay you like three two I
love three I think three is the best one
dude I love the cowboy one and I love
the the Austin Powers yeah look at the
weapon and Beverly Hills Cop never seen
Beverly Hills Cop and I think Beverly
Hills Ninja Axel Foley um
I don't think once and I've already seen
one of them Joe Pesci and Lethal Weapon
3 is incredible okay
he's great dude look at the fat ass on
this sheep oh my God
they're known for that ass
wow that ass is bad
that's it baby this is hey babe yeah uh
yeah
um Sal literally hasn't been at this
show in two months
all right listen if your holidays are
jam-packed you do not have time to cook
I got the perfect solution Factor meal
plans baby it's cheaper than dining out
it's healthy they got calories smart
vegan veggie they got keto Gourmet plus
it's awesome I use it comes right to the
house it's easy to unpack it's easy to
cook and the food tastes great and it's
healthy if you need a special occasion
meal Gourmet plus is the perfect
solution if you're looking for fast
upscale options done easy
factors everything you need for a week
of flavorful nutritious eats they got
smoothies energy bites extra protein I
love it right now all you got to do is
head to go dot factor75.com hey babe60
and use the code hey babe60 to get 60
off your first box that's code hey
babe60 at
go.factor75.com hey babe60 to get 60 off
your first box
Ridge wallet baby it's the wallet that I
have it's the wallet that I love it's
got It's the titanium steel uh uh color
um it's got the uh you you basically
can't get digitally pickpocketed when
you have this wallet it literally is the
perfect gift if you're looking for a
Christmas gift for your husband brother
boyfriend whatever Ridge wallet is it
even if you're a woman I mean ritual I
feel like my girl loves my Ridge wallet
wallet if get your wife a ridge wallet I
guarantee she'll love it she doesn't
want Chanel she wants a ridge wallet
okay the rich team is so confident that
you'll like it they'll let you test
drive it for 45 days and you can send it
back if you don't like it so boom you
literally have nothing to lose I love
the ridge wall it holds up to 12 Clark
cards plus room for cash it's got fifty
thousand five star reviews and it's
awesome
that's the it's got the RFID blocking
technology that protects you from the
digital pickpocketers baby that's what
it's about all you got to do is go to
ridge.com hey babe use the coupon code
hey babe and you're good to go ridge.com
hey babe promo code hey babe that's all
you got to do get your wife and husband
or both of them Ridge wallets right now
I have it I love it I'm sitting on mine
it's in my ass cracked he's a busy fella
we don't have TV shows yeah
genetically modified tobacco plant
produces cocaine in its leaves my
question is does it produce Fentanyl
that's the question well I found out in
my interview with the kid who did
Fentanyl and he compared it to heroin
and he said heroin was was way more
dangerous to him heroin was more
dangerous he said fentanyl is like a
boogeyman in the media but that's his
experience so fentanyl is covid and
heroin's the flu
yeah yeah that's what it is heroine's
day that guy didn't look like the most
trustworthy of sources
but he definitely did all the drugs see
I'm not on social media anymore so I
don't know what's going on with anyone
for you I don't see anybody I don't I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what's going on you know Jasmine my girl
will be like hey did you see this with
one what your friends did or she
mentioned oh did you see the pimpy the
cool interview I'm like I I don't have
social media good for you I don't know
and how's your life since then so it's
weird I'll tell you what it is I would
say better but I'm going through or I
was going through it more now it's more
balancing out where it's like because
you just take it away from you almost
cold turkey that you start to feel so
out of the loop and so insignificant
because you've been made to like I
didn't realize subconsciously my
personality and my uh uh like well-being
and my thoughts of like how do I feel
like my like view of myself like how do
I feel satisfactor as an individual was
linked to my social media profile it was
linked to likes and comments and now
that that's gone my brain I think
instantly got less dopamine so it
started to trick me into thinking well
I'm not doing anything and I'm not
valuable as a person
wow but it but it's but now it's evening
out I've realized that's what that was
and now I'm starting to feel so much
more valued as a person because instead
of those times on social media I'm
spending it all with my family and I'm
all with people who I actually know and
people who I actually have real
connections with so now I'm starting to
gain back the dopamine I think in a
healthier way well I want to zero in on
something you said it made you feel
insignificant is that not a freeing
feeling in a way to be like wow truly I
am just a small Speck of all this and so
in a way nothing I do matters except the
little circle that I have around me
right so make that Circle the best it
can be well that's that's exactly how I
feel now is I'm like that's great
because I was going through a point
where I said like it was even though I
was off and I knew that it was better
for me I couldn't help this
insignificance but now I was like
yesterday my favorite part of this is
Ian is inching closer to you as you're
saying I've notice that and I was gonna
say what's weirder the feeling of social
media the fact that I am so almost close
to kissing you
my fingers in my mouth
my hands oh my God I challenge but I get
it you do seem you do seem way better
off without it well I feel like I look
great you've lost weight well I don't
think they'll my weight loss and the
social media they go hand I don't think
one would have happened without the I
think if I was still on social media I
wouldn't be able to stick to the weight
loss because I think that inevitably I
would have seen something that
subconsciously made me upset and it made
me depressed all subconscious and then
subconscious I would have convinced
myself to not go to the gym to eat the
cupcake to do whatever but when I'm not
when I've removed it all and I'm just
around the people that I love or the
people that I know who are have all love
for me that are always saying push go
forward you know like my friends and
family are always like oh go to the gym
don't eat that like I only surrounded
myself with them very very little
outside stimuli I'm starting to reach
all these goals and I kind of feel like
you know everything that I do
in my life in my career I feel like um
I'm not comparing it to anyone else's
life or career so I'm happy with
whatever my results are because I'm only
comparing them to me weird so social
media made you feel defeated all the
time social media it's not a doubt
because it was too like [ __ ] it brought
in too many outside opinions that uh you
frankly shouldn't know I didn't know
yeah and so now I don't know about where
so now so now I feel happier and
healthier that way may I ask a question
yes uh
how do you go on your phone without
getting distracted to check something so
what I do is I have I have um you know
uh you know I still text a little bit
too much but at least it's people who I
know
um but I still that is too much that's
the next thing to to get past
um
I do read that uh I do read I feel like
I'll I'll start I'll check the news
Cycles uh sometimes I'll check my news
apps a little too much
um but that's what I do that's that's
the way what I get sucked into now is
news articles and texts but what I've
done is I've deleted all the news apps
now I only have one on my phone just the
New York but you and you deleted all the
social media apps I don't have because
you know what social media the devil
devil no
Devil's face down devil face down ass up
yeah that's it baby you're gonna get
eaten by the cocaine there
but now listen I know I'm in a you know
privileged position I have somebody
running my social media for like you
know I still post on it every day but I
just make the video or write the tweet
and send it to my guy who posted for me
so they they see so I'm still actively
posting but I don't have any part of it
uh which you know is is very curious
I tell my guy like hey if anybody says
anything crazy let me know
um and he will at times but you know if
somebody like DMS about a business
opportunity they'll send it to me and
then I'll respond uh but I you know do I
get curious yeah but uh but I just kind
of know how bad it is for me and I just
try to stay away no that's great I think
part of comedy's outgrowing it you know
yeah the bigger Headliners don't touch
social
yeah I also kind of feel like you you
still post but they're not they have
people behind it like you still have to
pump it out but there's yeah I'd love to
get yeah I also too just from a comedy
point of view was like you know the more
I'm on social media the more
subconsciously I'll just be like
everybody else if I want to be different
then you got to be different man you
know like and the only way that it's not
even trying to be different it's like
well if I have if I have no outside
influence and I'm just kind of seeing it
calling it how I see it then you know I
got a better chance of being original
but listen I know it's not for everybody
and some people maybe didn't have the
social media addiction I had but I just
knew something needed to change not only
not only my weight man my [ __ ] blood
pressure went down 40 points my
cholesterol went down like 75 points
everything's down my blood sugar went
down like everything changed whoa
imagine I just stepped out the window
right now on camera
I've never felt better
so I I don't know but I I don't think
that it happens without uh I don't even
know if it's getting off social media
for everybody but it is having real
connections with people is that's really
what I went for is totally I just wanted
to connect with my daughters connect
with my girl connect with my mom and dad
like talk to them as opposed to
connecting on dm with a stranger and
then you know you know then then you
know you get in trouble that way you
start messaging people feelings you get
into relationships uh you know like
because you want that little hit it's
it's all a dope it's a little dopamine
head out you know you'd find yourself
messaging someone guy or a girl
romantically or not all these feelings
and personal things because you're
getting this dopamine and it's not real
yeah it's not a real connection where's
this going yeah it's gonna be this for
the rest of my life or are you just
going to become a disposable person that
just slowly dies out yeah and then I
take 12 hours five days to get back to
you and then it's just like you were in
my life yeah and then you message each
other six months later and you think
it's the first time you're ever talking
and then it's only until you realize
eyes oh you corresponded with each other
six months ago about [ __ ] it's
because it and then it gets people in
trouble like you know like you say
things you say too much and so I just
was like you know what let me just get
off it and when I'm at a point where I
feel like I could go on it and do it
responsibly I would do it but oh but
honestly it's a drug for you yeah it's a
drug but to be honest totally related
not even not even not even about
responsible or not I kind of just don't
miss it I I understand the need for it
for
um
you know my career or whatever but like
not being connected to everyone actually
I I can tell you just as a human
first-hand experience is the way it's
supposed to be you're not supposed to be
connected to everything no this whole
idea that we all need to be connected is
not a good human experiment it's not
it's not what our brains and Harmony the
experiment has failed yeah things were
built and things were made because
people weren't you know worrying about
like oh did you know that something
happened in Aleppo it's like well no I'm
no we have to build City Hall yeah you
know no it it's you're totally right and
also the psychic weight of knowing the
plight of so many people whether they're
close to you or what's going on I do
think that humans at their base are good
and empathetic and want good things and
I think that's why we're at such a point
right now where everyone's at each
other's throats and everyone's upset
because we know so much and we feel
helpless that we can't change it right
so that weight weighs on people and it
truly depresses people and then
depression is just anger return Edward
and then you're mean to other people and
you snap just again to get like a little
bit of dopamine to feel yeah and it's
like you gotta feel by feeling the
things around you you know well dude and
I just feel like you know it's I gotta
check my email
that's a bit that I thought about a
minute ago I love it where I go on my
social media
[ __ ] love it but what I said was true
but talking about weird connections this
remind me of Chris for some reason I
thought you'd love is that a Prince
Henry uh Prince William this woman met
the man who inherited her dead
daughter's heart Amber Morgan from
Indiana met 68 year old Tom Johnson four
years after he received a heart from
andronia Williams who was just 20 when
she died from asthma in 2018.
so Morgan listened to a stethoscope
pressed to Johnson's chest in an
emotional moment for the pair
oh it's almost like I got to hug my
daughter again wow so he she heard her
daughter's heart in this man's chest wow
so now is he trans
[Laughter]
oh that is that is um that is to go back
to older episodes you said Oregon donors
might inherit some of the problems yes
so so organ donor so we talked about
this on a on a hey babe a few weeks ago
we talked about this on a hey babe last
year when Sal was on the show
and um and so so this basically what
happened was is this
woman uh uh this guy died and he was a
carpenter okay like a like a or like or
a construction worker like a foreman
like good with his hands and then gave
and it was a uh this woman needed a
kidney transplant so he died and then
they gave his kidney to this woman the
kidney not the heart just the kidney and
then all of a sudden the woman woke up
and started building buildings and was
like a full construction worker yeah she
had her ass crack down she was hitting
on girls walking by yeah hey what's up
sweet tits you want to get hammered so
she so no way yeah so there's there's a
lot of research Is that real or is that
like a thing of like this girl got MRSA
and then all she could do was walk
backwards no to see those stories no
this is real this pieces of it just like
kids who have memories of past lives
yeah like so they think now two things
they think that one the mind is not only
in your brain they think like your mind
mind is actually in your cells which are
all over your body so that's why this
woman got a kidney but her cells you
know her set the man's cells had
memories in them they think your
memories are in your cells so they think
your memories and your mind and the way
you think is not just in your brain it
is all through your cell so I could give
you a piece of my body an organ in my
body and it can put my memories and my
thoughts into your body but does that
mean then that not only so she doesn't
have the vivid memory of like
construction stuff she has the muscle
memory to end the skill set to then yes
she could not even she says she couldn't
even hold like a hammer to a nail and
then she got this kidney in her and she
had this burning desire to like she
would put up sheetrock she would like
burning
[Laughter]
she's at night just racked with stress
like I gotta I gotta hang drywall
please please oh I gotta mud some seams
can you do construction yeah I used to
be a carpenter so you could do anything
like you could if I was like hey man I
need you to build up a build a wall for
me you could do that one two three I
used to uh before I moved out of the
city in 2008 I used to go around to Sky
town and different places and build
partition walls for roommates to corner
off like another room or something
instead of like a studio and it's just a
curtain I would build like the wall so
how do you do that what's the first step
in building a wall well let me tell you
something really good I'm stud
what I do is just look in the mirror
well you know studs are 16 inches on
Center and uh you know you got to
measure everything out and plan it out
and uh you know measure twice cut once
you know is it tedious work
I mean when you're learning but then it
just becomes like you just imagine so
you would just measure from ceiling my
skill right now would be probably not
good because it's been yeah it's been
like a decade no more since I was like a
full-time Carpenter but when I was
getting really good at it and I was
getting like side work and going out on
jobs on my own and everything dude I was
getting [ __ ] woo hips leaking cool
with it brother and I was like I'll just
drink
no job that scared you you got to a
point where you could walk into my age
I'd be like I could do it no no no I had
guys that were like the the
pros and then I was like I started out
as like the helper and then like I got
more responsibility and they would like
teach me as I went along like tiling a
bathroom or building a partition wall or
something great I love it but like me
alone framing out a basement I couldn't
do that I couldn't do her like an
addition or you know like I could put up
like crown molding and and stuff like
that like install Windows and stuff but
like so what was the weirdest kitchen's
like doing a whole kitchen I couldn't do
do that like no right yeah cause like I
can't even like there's actually I'm
getting my kitchen remodel now and the
guys that are doing it like I don't even
know I I was looking at the kitchen
before you know they started ripping
apart it was like I wouldn't even know
where to begin what to pull out first or
even how to pull it out I wouldn't I
don't even know how to pull my
refrigerator out they're like oh I swear
to God they were like they're like can
when you pull your refrigerator out they
were like is your refrigerator when it
pulls out or like they were asking me
about like the electrical in the
dishwasher and I was like I don't know
how can I see the electrical from the
dishwasher they were like well the
fridge out I was like yeah but it's too
heavy they were like no no it's on
wheels and a sliding track and I and I
was like they were like your kid can
pull it out and I was like what like I
am child labor like is there a class
that I could take for adults that's like
just learning how to build stuff
one-on-one yeah like learning go to a
tech school I got a certificate in basic
carpentry before I started it was great
but I could go back to tech school now
yes just go to it yes just go and
they'll teach you you got free time
you're not on social media no seriously
yeah and then I'll just learn a train
take a class can but how do I go into
how do I get into tech school you'd find
a local Technical Institute and you
apply you pay for the class you go two
nights a week and you learn a trade and
then you start to work and you get a job
for like minimum wage as a Helper and
you work your way up that's right you
know Jordan
she was a carpenter and she one time
gate had a job that she couldn't do she
had surgery and she like gave it to me
she was a carpenter but she couldn't
bring the wood yeah that's right she's
not a guy yeah it's a stud finder not a
[ __ ] fight yeah
do you guys talk about carpentry on your
part yeah well that's the thing so our
podcast being in with Jordan he
he uh for I think for one of the pay
we're gonna like build a shed or
something like go down to Delaware at my
mom's house and like build something
really yeah so do you think Jordan is
better than you at building stuff yes
like she knew actually she did it for
longer she grew up with it she built a
house with her dad I was just a
carpenter for like five years I was like
a Helper and then I build up to like be
getting jobs on my own and there was a
guy that like really took me under his
wing and helped me yeah because it's a
big insecurity ass not knowing how to
build or do anything so the only way to
get around that is to go to a school and
[ __ ] learn how to do it can I go to
Home Depot and do a class yeah I don't
know it's not like the Apple Store like
you just sit and there's a guy in a
headset I have to like go to a trade
school YouTube I have a buddy who framed
his basement remodeled his basement just
by watching YouTube yeah no skills no
skills Robert Kelly did the same thing
he built a pirate ship in his backyard
for his kid for YouTube they told you
exactly step by step Robert Kelly did it
yeah what to do so what do I Google like
remodeling kitchen for idiots or that
would be a start okay yeah let's pull
let's see what we cannot do dude Google
remodeling kitchen for idiots see if I
can even follow along anything also by
the way we're live on hey Babe's
Instagram the fans are chiming in is Sal
dead yes no Sal got this is Sal hey
what's up I'm Sal I love arguing about
food
uh yeah let's do kitchen yeah like uh uh
Florida doctor accused of killing
patients that's not what we're looking
for oh raping patients found dead that's
good let's go
um so oh oh oh he was raping patients
and then they found him dead all right
good that he's dead yeah he's dead yes
um so how to put up a wall how to build
it okay
but see even this what what do I get I
don't have any of these tools okay so
you measure out what you want oh dude
shopping is great can we go tool
shopping maybe bro I would [ __ ] love
that you know you like to be a mate dude
I love the toy on tool aisle I'm so
excited I can't even say it yeah I
picked up a fella at Lowe's one I bought
a tool I didn't even need just so I
could chat him up yeah all right dude
I'm telling you it is so fun getting
like a list of supplies picking them out
getting everything together loading it
up in the truck unloading getting to
work
because when I look at that when I look
at like like I saw a guy today actually
I was pulled over because I had to sign
a lease because we're getting it we're
getting a new I'm getting a new podcast
studio for this okay thanks baby
you'll come see it hey and um and uh
um and so so oh my God I'm thinking
about tile saws but but when a guy I saw
a guy on uh you know opening the back of
his construction van and he had so much
[ __ ] in there like planks of wood and
tools and I literally was getting
light-headed thinking about how long
it's going to take to clear that out and
where he's even gonna put it and what
but you would look at that and be like
that looks awesome yes see well dude
it's it's like yo you could get like a
truck or a van and then you build stuff
in the van to house the tools and you
use like uh I I would use old um coffee
like tins for like
my three-quarter inch nails 5 8 wood
screws metal screws 10 penny nails right
so I don't have to go to a trade school
no but that's fun come on I thought we
were going to trade schools
it is like really really but but at the
end of the day it's back breaking work
the longevity of it is I mean dude the
smartest thing you can do is [ __ ] get
your union card and you're an apprentice
any work your way up to journeyman and
then on the weekend dude the best was
like working jobs on the weekends to
make money to upgrade your tools so that
you could then like work better at your
job and then work better on the side job
right but like it's back breaking work
it's you know you're up early you're out
late you're you're outside in the
elements I hate having wet socks I got
my socks wet I went home one day oh that
sucks
dude the guys who are doing my backyard
and kitchen my whole house like under
the renovation right now which is I by
the way don't if you don't if your house
doesn't absolutely need a renovation do
not do it because once it started
opening up walls now they need to be a
retaining wall now there's a crack in
the foundation now it just adds money
money bro it's kind of like my I I'm
going to apply it like my surgery rule
if you don't absolutely need the surgery
don't get it I should have taken that
advice with my home it was not I
understand that's making my house nicer
and it's going to be lovely but do not
[ __ ] get renovation in your house if
you don't need it please and then it's
you got is this up to code can you do
this that's load bear you got it like
good God cutting the the wrong well now
Jasmine fought with our neighbor over
some [ __ ] with the with the fence no
and now the neighbor said she's calling
the city because the pool is within five
feet of her property so now I gotta
[ __ ] move my pool
I just paid all this money to get my
pool resized now they got to move the
pool what'd she say they that somebody
was she popping was it a popular it was
a dispute about offense whose fence is
it is it our fence or her fence and this
woman was saying it was her fence and
Jazz was saying it was offense I was
like jazz you don't know who's [ __ ]
fence it is but how do you determine
who's fencing well I called the previous
I called the owner uh the previous owner
who we bought the house from and he said
that it was his fence and he was like
don't but that woman is crazy she'll
pull a gun out on you so he said if I if
that was me I would say just build a
fence in front of her fence if you need
to have a retaining wall for your new
pool or whatever build the fence in
front of her fence and don't touch her
don't even if it is your fence which it
is just give up eight inches of your
property so she doesn't call the city
because she will and then I was call on
my way to call Jazz to tell her that and
she was like Hey the woman said she's
gonna call the city because our pools
within five feet I said why she's like
because I went over there and called her
a [ __ ] I was like oh great
great
that's so I should have just
[ __ ] but I really got to learn how to
build stuff it is something that keeps
me up at night that I I am not a man and
I don't know how to use my hands for any
type of skill whatsoever the
construction it doesn't Define a man but
it but the construction workers I mean
they they literally they make fun of me
they call me princesses
hey what's up lipstick yeah I'm flapping
around in my pool
they they and they're not wrong I mean
they you know they carried in a [ __ ]
400 pound beam today like I I don't you
know I and I'm just why I'm literally
sitting up there watching doing
breathing techniques to prepare for a
podcast
how'd that gas leak go I heard you had a
gas leak what do you have a gas leak
yeah you were going on about yeah it was
me and my apartment oh yes yes yes if
there was a gas leak in the house right
right right yeah no that uh they fixed
it but the homeowner sounds exhausting
it's exhausting it's being a parent and
a homeowner is pretty uh bro it's pretty
exhausting it's pretty exhausting but I
guess it's what you're supposed to do I
I don't I don't know but it is tar like
I thought about this the other day you
know having you know three kids or
whatever I haven't had truthfully like
you know like those sleeps that you get
when you lay down you're like oh finally
like and you have no worries I haven't
had that in eight years wow and I
probably my mother actually let me in on
some news over Thanksgiving because I
relayed that to her and she was like
honey you're never gonna have that again
because you're a parent now my mother
was like you're 38 years old I I've
never felt relaxed because you're a your
child is either with you and you're
worried about it worried that you know
they're they're okay or worried about
school when they're a little kid worried
about you know you got to get up for
them and then when they're when you
moved out I just worry that you're okay
almost every night I have to call my mom
back she she called me yeah I didn't
call her back yeah well sometimes I mean
I know I always say pick up the phone
for your mom and dad but sometimes when
they're calling you every day you're
like I can't pick up every day yeah I
like what am I gonna say nothing well
I'm such an [ __ ] we talked to the
other night and she's like you you
haven't called me since you saw me I go
well you know how a phone works huh and
then she uses the phone and I'm like
I'm a little prick yeah I know sometimes
my mother will call me she's like
remember me I'm your mother I'm like
yeah I would never forget your piercing
[ __ ] voice
how did your Tri-State Thanksgiving go
try to say Thanksgiving was good trying
to say Thanksgiving so I had to here's
what here's my Thanksgiving well I had
to with my whole family with jazz and my
three kids I had to drive all the way
from Staten Island to Ridgewood New York
which is takes about an hour and 15
minutes more hour and a half with
traffic pick up my mother then go from
Ridgewood Queens all the way to
Ridgewood New Jersey which was
geographically much closer to Staten
Island so I had to go an hour and a half
out of the way to now come two hours
back to go to New Jersey spend
Thanksgiving in New Jersey which we all
were uh uh brewing with the flu which we
didn't know which everybody in their
house got the Bluetooth so we all were
sitting there silently with the flu uh
which we didn't know we were [ __ ]
incubating and then drive my mom all the
way back from Ridgewood New Jersey to
Ridgewood New York in Queens then drop
her off and then drive from Richmond New
York back to Staten Island and it I was
in the car for five and a half hours and
a Thanksgiving for two and nobody at all
cared if I was tired or what I wanted or
what I needed I just had to suck it up
and [ __ ] drive and then wake up the
next day and get called a princess by
the construction workers might I say
you know we were talking about cell
memories and everything I have such fond
Vivid memories of hating things at the
time when I was younger but now in
hindsight being like that was great like
what what wonderful you know like just
like having to get everything together
and like oh we're running late and then
like going down to the beach and this
and that but it's like man those are
such beautiful times that uh you either
have the choice of being like this is
stressful this is terrible which it is
I'm not taking away from that but like
man getting to spend that time with the
family like you don't know when little
pockets of those memories are gonna pop
into your like daughter's head be like
like she'll drive on a road that you
guys are driving on and be like man I
was with my grandma and my dad and that
was really wonderful well she was asleep
the entire
I'm like isn't that beautiful right now
she was [ __ ] knocked out she
literally stupid you don't have a family
you know the stress I go through with
this everything's nice within five
minutes of us leaving my house her mom
said she couldn't watch YouTube on our
phone anymore and it was taken away and
she smashed my window and then said I'm
going to sleep and then didn't wake up I
swear to God she didn't wake up at all
until we got to New Jersey then sat in
the corner and sulked in the corner we
had to bring her a piece of turkey and
mashed potatoes like she was a field
mouse and she ate on the floor mad
because she was incubating with the flu
the entire way home and then woke up the
next morning and said she was
constipated from the Advil I don't think
[Laughter]
at the moments you are sadly mistaken
okay she gets her information and her
feelings from Jojo siwa and her
conversion therapy
well everyone in my family's dead so I
have no choice but to look back fondly
and be like oh that was wonderful dude
look at this kid he could do a one-armed
organize one arm where did uh where does
other arm go
I know
wow what oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that kid's
strong
oh
wow oh God that kid is so [ __ ] I
would have I there's not a chance in
hell I could even come close I couldn't
even get that up to my knees could you
get the bar you could do that maybe the
bar with one arm yeah 20 pound 30 pounds
45 I mean what are those 45 pound plates
on your side yeah yeah three or two
three yeah no yeah
that's over 300 pounds then or close to
300 pounds wow damn look at that guy in
the wheelchair in the background being
like damn is this a gym for the
handicapped oh interesting maybe is it
yeah everybody's everybody's limbless or
in the wheelchair
wow oh look at how fat that guy is in
the background with the blue shorts I
know he's so jealous he's like [ __ ] he's
like I still got both arms and I can
walk
that's what he says
when he leaves
out of the way Wheels the wheels dude
how are you gonna drink this Mountain
Dew fruit Quake what fruit Quake what is
fruit Quake what a kind of good name man
fruit Quake it's supposed to taste like
fruit cake yeah
supposed to taste like your
grandmother's fruitcake but it's fruit
Quake oh does it come with guilt and
arguments yeah I'm not I'm not a
fruitcake fan at all like I never I am
never like a people
100 welcome to Qatar
um shout out Mateo special shout out
Mateo special ghost go watch the tail
light special it's called live from
Qatar with material Lake
um no Mateo Lane's new special is
fantastic I posted about it go check it
out it's on YouTube oh he's great but
but I'm I will now I'll say this I'm a
dessert I love desserts I would never
order a dessert with the fruit in it
that The Fruitcake I never got on board
never who likes fruitcake can you tell
us here at hey babe right at you know
either Instagram us and at hey babe
Potter write in the comments on the
YouTube of this episode do you like
fruitcake I mean what is a good like
what is appetizing about fruit in your
dessert
speaking of fruitcakes you see this
liver King guys on steroids you haven't
seen this liver King dude yes of course
he's on steroids why do people lie how
does how could he with a straight face
say he's not on that steroid belly right
yeah yeah look at it yes clearly he's on
this is not shocking but who do you hate
more him or the the kid who did the big
crypto Bernie Madoff [ __ ] well that kid
that you know what's interesting about
that kid I think it's um what is the
what was the crypto thing FTX FTX that
kid went on I think it was like good day
in New York or NBC Today one of the big
like morning shows and kind of like
apologized and like went against all
lawyers all his lawyers uh advice and
was like yeah I'm sorry like I didn't
know any of this was illegal I I thought
I was just uh kind of doing well in
business like it is like yeah yeah he
spoke out he was like yeah I'm
responsible as the CEO and um
I'm sorry this this this guy who
interviewed him has two different
colored eyes so it's freaking me out
yeah former so I think he's gonna go to
prison this kid though right yeah
what happened with him customers out
here he literally had all these like
famous people throw money at him a lot
of people threw money at him but then he
just kind of invested it into his own
currency that he started it was that
fake thing like birdie Madoff it's right
exactly Bernie Madoff he took the money
and invested it in himself and spent the
money uh-huh yeah I think everyone
pulled out and revealed that he had no
yeah scheme yeah how do you be like I
thought he was business I didn't know it
was illegal that there's something in
crypto I think wait pimp play the are we
gonna get flagged for this no no it's
accomplished by me just sitting more go
go ahead a little bit go to like where
they're back here
investigating he is living in the
Bahamas that's where he had Incorporated
the company to live outside of the
jurisdiction of the United States by the
way his parents law professors at
Stanford University
um and he said wait no go back go back
to when this guy's talking in the
beginning because he explains yeah hold
on hold go yeah go go to the beginning
googly eye Jenkins wait go go back to
express some control go forward
like this part I screwed up like no
forward more
forward right here everybody worth 32
billion now he's got like a hundred
thousand dollars yeah he explains what
he did is the is this is what he's
saying like I had no idea what went
wrong is that plausible I think a lot of
people ask that question this morning
and whether his answers were truthful
what appears to have happened is he was
running the equivalent of a stock
exchange taking people's money yeah that
they thought they were investing in
cryptocurrencies he was also running
another hedge fund his own investment
firm investing in cryptocurrencies and
he was quote unquote loaning money from
those people to himself and then
gambling with that money some people
call that stealing
um he says that he didn't intend to do
that and he didn't realize what was
happening but of course as you might
imagine lots of people asking lots of
questions that was the best Subway I've
ever heard so far yeah isn't that just
the stock market you take people's money
and then well put it in something and
then well I think that's what the this
CEO was saying is I think that that he's
saying like hey you gave me your million
dollars and it's I put it in different
kinds of crypto because that's what you
said like you know that this is a bed
and uh investment or a volatile
investment but I think the problem was
is he was then I guess taking some of
the money and putting in his own pocket
Maybe
he was using it to invest he was just
gambling with it think of it as gambling
yeah but that's but that's what stock
Brokers do yeah yeah but they don't
literally they tell you hey you're
giving me this money to go gamble it
they don't say hey you're investing in a
stock right but did this all fall
because everyone caught wind and pulled
their I think it felt because a rival
somehow public somehow found out
supposedly he's not the first guy that's
gonna go down uh or who stock uh whose
crypto firm is going to go down because
I think that the government too like
they can't regulate this is obviously
decentralized currency they can't
regulate it so I think that the
government is probably doing like their
own things in-house so we don't even
know about that it's causing all these
collapses because they want crypto out
of here yeah I think the government
doesn't want it I mean I don't [ __ ]
know dude I invested in crypto two years
ago when everyone did it because I'm a
hack and now I don't even know my
password so it's over yeah and now
you're trusting tank to go to Costa Rica
yeah now I'm going to Costa Rica [ __ ]
tank Sinatra what yeah dude dude some
kid
have you ever been to Costa Rica no you
think it's safe to go why wouldn't it be
safe that's the new place to go because
everything's cheap I said it's not safe
for you why yeah why you're chaos
because he's pale he's [ __ ] chaos oh
can we go back to that liver King thing
real quick because have you ever seen
the videos of his son liver boy
who's liver boy his son that does the
liver King things of like eating liver
and all this stuff okay and in these
videos it truly looks like his dad is
behind the camera with a gun making him
do this he's like I love eating liver
and then you see him bite it and he goes
[Laughter]
liver wife oh Rihanna farts oh God I
would do anything to smell it I would
clean up her [ __ ] water I would dig my
grandmother up and punch her in the
sternum just to smell it
what yeah I wonder why liver was the
best thing liver boy Striker that's his
son's name let's see
private Striker Liverpool yeah of course
you're on steroids look at him he does
his dedicated he thinks we're out here
building some stuff for social media
we're gonna go hunt them down they're
hunting his son
what did liver boy ever say liver King
ever say he wasn't on steroids and he
gets his Jack by just eating liver or
did he just not promoting a lifestyle
and a Diet got it yeah and he makes his
money off sup up off like uh weights
that's right here hit a holistic brand
here here's my thing with this email how
do we know that that's real because it
truly it's a cut off screenshot with no
other information well even if anyone
could make you know like with emails and
even like text now can anybody deep fake
anybody and be like how do you prove
that that really is yeah you that's why
a video is not admissible in court you
have to really prove it's real videos
what do you mean video footage is not
fully admissible it could be deep fake
now that happens during the pandemic it
used to be admissible yeah right
right
it's a liver boy rad on Instagram there
he is
there he is liver boy Savage liver boy
rad boom we got him all right so this is
go down and look at the one where he's
in a pool and he's about to eat here
show us seeing which one oh down down
down no that's what yeah right to the
right to the right down down one more
that one that's it
this is the one
here not the doctor said my favorite
tents right now like cold and eat
little boy out
did you see at the ending some of my
favorite tents right now like cold and
eat cold and eat
blue boy out
[Music]
here and pause it at the end trying to
get his face at the very end pippy
Blue Boy
[Laughter]
somebody wrote boy you about to throw up
go warm up your chicken now
yeah he's in a cold plunge water he's
gonna get hated every second and eat
nasty Raw Liver it's had for some money
bro these children are gonna be so
confused yep bro he looks like he fit a
boss
we gotta start saying finna more yeah
I'm Finning to say it more so look
somebody said my dog got a gun pointed
out for sure behind that phone bro yeah
so [ __ ] up that's not child abuse I
guess I don't know dude there's other
videos where he's like just looks like a
hostage I mean weird I'm sure he is oh
yeah look maybe this one he's eating
again
let's see
I'm the son of liver King
little boy out
uh
free liver boy liver yeah he's
definitely not enjoying it bro being
forced to yeah I mean this kid's gonna
be a weird kid let's see do his
deadlifts suck probably does he should I
bet the one arm guy is better than him
yeah
I mean the kid he's definitely gonna be
jacked this kid right yeah
but look his dad probably makes him have
that dumb haircut
he's not only this he's posting on his
social media like boxing skills let's
see if I'm just like my dad and
everyone's like you stink yeah
ancestral tenants fight
I think he's the next round to Santos
dude he's got my vote
um yeah man I uh I don't think that I
ever
I don't
so it goes looks like he belongs behind
an Xbox controller
dude I don't think that I'd ever
ever raw sushi yep that's it I can't eat
I don't want to eat raw I don't even do
steak tartare I won't eat raw meat
really you like steak tartar yeah I'll
do it but it's Gotta Have a little quail
egg on it I've never had a quail egg bro
a Dan quail egg you got
nice yeah
uh I will try anything if you give I'll
try it but I'm not gonna finish it like
I'll take a bite and then be like but
like have you ever gone to Fogo de Chao
yes and they they have like chicken
liver or whatever I've tried it hated it
disgusting
it's cooked it's gross like why it's
just like chewy yeah oh have you ever
had tripe whole stripe oh it's like the
inside I think it's the inside of like
stomach lining or something of a cow
you're like yeah or or like um cattle
Pig sheep yeah if you eat like a chicken
foot or something like if you go to a
Chinese market I don't know if I need
some of that some of that stuff's oh oh
yeah oh God
ugh right because tripe doesn't sound
too unappetizing it's like oh tribe
sounds like it could be good but tripe
is gross yeah but if you dip it in like
soy sauce or something it'll really take
that stomachs of various animals yeah
cattles pigs and sheep yep yep
I guess you have to use every part right
I mean we're not Native Americans dude
you sent me a picture
couldn't you just buy a pig head at
something yeah I didn't know DeRosa got
new headshots
hey now you could just buy a whole pig
down at the market in the seaport but
what would you do with a pig head it was
crazy they have cuts of meat there
that's like 200 and I went with my mom
and she's like how much of this do you
throw out and he goes every night we
throw out most of it lower the cuts of
meats are 200 like a steak it's like
it's for like Rich bougie people this
tin building that just opened up yeah
it's like steak cuts all those he goes
we have to throw it out every night
right otherwise the rich people complain
I'm like where is that I'll buy from
there the dumpster yeah wow
I want to explore this area you used to
you said you used to change printers in
this area right or fix printers yeah
nice wow dude so you did carpentry you
fix printers yep yeah it was uh it was a
Pitney Bowes repair man oh yeah let's
get into a real wacky printer job oh
buddy you better believe it well they're
all in the mail rooms at these
multi-million dollar offices and mail
rooms are like Abercrombie and Fitch
like they have like the hot people up
front at the desk and then the real
freaks and slimers are in the back in
the mail room just like Hunchback like
the machine won't work and I would go in
and do it sometimes it would be really
funny because I would be in like an
office and I'd hear like the gossip and
uh one time this girl was like and he
does this and this and that and I'm
fixing the printer and when I get done I
go all right the printer's fixed and
also Angela you deserve better
oh my God but it was it was amazing it
was multi-million dollar companies with
this machine that no one knew how to
work and I'd walk in and be their God
because they had to mail they'd never be
shitty to you if they knew no they were
like really I was like the hero they're
they're it stopped all their mail when
this thing wouldn't work so I would walk
in and sometimes they'd be like we don't
know what's wrong we don't know what to
do oh my God I'd be like oh it's not on
yeah and I'd have to turn a switch and
then be like all right pay me right it's
pretty great I rode my bicycle around
town it was awesome man it was all yeah
in this downtown area yeah I mean I you
you've had you've had these jobs where
you know dude because you're a carpenter
everyone thinks of course Jesus it'd be
wild if this is the new kind of Jesus is
that you were a carpenter then you turn
into you know stand-up comedy and
podcasting and you're just you know
you're bisexual and you have the [ __ ]
water clean up instead of turning one
into water you turned into ship water
and I was a teacher Jesus teaches Jesus
taught I'm an only child yep I was told
my mom's a virgin yeah uh this is the
new hair yeah yeah yeah yeah I wow what
if I am yeah the new Jesus you could
frequently could be heard on Legion of
skanks
I got a new show coming out on compound
media Jesus Jew Talk
Jesus you talk jjt did you know that
Jesus historically it's a fact he had a
huge penis what yeah how could it be a
fact though because he was hung like
this
hey yeah
that's right baby that's right and I can
make jokes like that because I am Jesus
that's it baby that's the kind of jokes
we have here in Delco County maybe we
should end on that Helen Keller joke you
had yeah
well plug your dates plug your stand up
dates yeah and then and then right after
that you're gonna hear the kind of
Comedy Ian's gonna give you a little bit
of supreme so you buy the tickets
oh my God okay come on let the people
know where to find you and then get
ready to get your wallets out yes
December 8th Pittsburgh improv uh and
then the end of the month I'm with the
great David tell at Caroline's on
Broadway the 20 uh 8th 29th and 30th and
then dude I'm telling you I'm going all
over in January and February Denver
Comedy Works uh Detroit House of Comedy
uh Fairfield comedy club I'm going to
zany Chicago zany's Nashville it's gonna
to be a time I got a ton of other dates
ianfidance.com I animal 69 on Instagram
and B and Ian with Jordan
yeah this is a podcast take us out on
that joke baby
how did Helen Keller wait here it is
how did Helen Keller's parents punish
her as a kid how they stuck the plunger
in the toilet this has been anything
[Music]
laughs
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe